hi there steve kaufman here uh again to
talk about languages and language
learning
uh if you enjoy these videos please
subscribe
i appreciate all the questions and
comments that i receive
and i try to answer them on the comment
section uh at youtube
but some of them are interesting and i
get requests you know would you please
do a video on this and that and i
appreciate that i i sometimes forget
them so you can remind me
uh but there was a question asking me
what did i think of interslavic
and that's why i googled
and interslavic was a project to
develop some form of slavic language
which would be sort of a bridge between
the different slavic languages
so that
i guess it made it easier for slavic
language speakers to communicate with
each other or that was the intention
there is also something called
interlingua which was the same idea to
create some kind of a neutral
uh
sort of romance language that would be
you know easy for speakers of different
romance languages to learn what do i
think of these projects
essentially i'm not a big fan
and you know you could almost throw uh
esperanto into the mix
uh as being sort of an
artificially created language that's
supposed to facilitate communication
i'm not a fan for myself
i always say people should learn the
languages that interest them whatever
those languages may be
by the way i had someone comment that i
was a racist because i didn't learn
native
mexican languages and i only learned
european languages
whereas in fact i have learned four
asian languages and i'm learning arabic
right now i mean we can learn whatever
language we want and i don't think we
should
criticize people or
draw any conclusions based on what they
learn but insofar as myself as far in
insofar as what interests me
i like learning languages that have a
history a country a cuisine a culture
a genuine native speakers and i know the
esperanto is saying say that there are
native speakers of esperanto but not in
any meaningful sense or meaningful
quantity you're unlikely to go to
esperanto land and sit beside
even in an airplane sit beside someone
who can speak esperanto so i'm not
motivated so if we get back to
interslavic
i guess it's possible to come up with
some kind of a sort of neutral slavic
language which reduces the sort of
idiosyncrasies of each slavic language
which is easily written in cyrillic and
latin you know alphabet
but i would i learned that language i
started out with russian because it has
the largest numbers of speaker speakers
it has the best known
literature culture and so forth it's a
huge country it's tremendously
attractive to learn russian to be to be
introduced to that world would i take
the interim step of learning
into slavic i don't think so
uh
i i having learned now a number of
slavic languages to varying degrees of
proficiency i think in a way
slovak kind of does that because slovak
is seems to be the most easily
understood slow slow back or
slavic language kind of closer to polish
closer to ukrainian even closer to some
of the south slavic languages
and equally distant from russian as is
czech or polish so
um
you know and there you have a country
you have a history and you can go and
visit bratislava and eat their food and
stuff so i'm not a fan of that the same
with the romance languages interlingua
why wouldn't you just learn spanish
which is the most widely spoken of the
romance languages and then use that as a
base to then focus on other
romance languages which will then be
easier because you have actually learned
one of them
uh
so there you have it interslavic
interlingua that's kind of my feeling
same with esperanto i understand that
esperanto is easy to learn and i have
i understand that it would be a useful
subject to have in school young children
who essentially will learn whatever you
ask them to learn
and if they learn esperanto and they
have immediate success in being able to
use the language that may very well
encourage them to learn other languages
so i see that as quite useful but as an
adult i don't i wouldn't you know i need
to get
sort of really into the language
which is what i'm doing with arabic you
know i am sure that it would be far
easier for me to learn esperanto uh it's
been about a month since i started into
arabic my ipad is never far away i try
to get in an hour an hour and a half of
of linking and listening and i still
don't understand very well when i listen
but i do have a sense that i am
improving
uh you know you can study the arabic
letters and then when you see them again
in the word and you keep making the same
mistakes and so
at times it's frustrating but but i i
had the sense this morning that i was
actually getting a little bit better
which reminds me of something else that
i'll finish off on and that is
you know
people often sort of say well are you a
linguist or are you a polyglot well i
really wasn't familiar that familiar
with the word polyglot 10 years ago and
i asked around in our office and most
this is in vancouver and i would say
that at least 10 years ago most native
speakers of english didn't know what the
word polyglot meant
most native speakers of english
understood the word linguist to mean
someone who speaks many languages or is
good at languages at languages he's
quite the linguist he speaks many
languages
now i've become more familiar with the
word polyglot so i tend to use the word
polyglot more
and linguist is used for people who
study linguistics now in the linguistics
area there are a number of terms
that are used in applied linguistics uh
one of which is interlanguage
and interlanguage is sort of this
concept that when we are learning a
second language we tend to use a
language that is a mixture of our own
and the
language we're trying to learn
i've never understand why i understood
why that would be a useful
term because
you know i'm nowhere in arabic
and there will be a gradual continuum
until i get good at arabic
those languages which are similar to our
own i think those are the languages
where
often
we will maintain
some phrases from our
own language
for example i hear swedish people and i
have done a lot of business in sweden
who are very fluent in english
uh oh and by the way i was very
impressed in listening to the norwegian
uh prime minister speaking
so well in english and a lot of the
scandinavians are very fluent in english
but there are certain phrases that that
remain there from their native language
for example in english we say there are
there is
there are
lots of trees in
vancouver
and lots of swedish people will say it
is many trees because that's how it's
said in swedish or german people who say
i have lived in canada since many years
instead of four many years however while
they speak there are these remnants
you know it can also go the other way
where you know and i should say that if
the languages are more different then
there are phrases that you learn
in that
new language which are so different from
your own that there's no chance
uh
you know of confusing you you start
saying things automatically like um
like how about that there is no
equivalent in english so you just
naturally start to say these phrases in
the language
you know i saw think we don't say i so
think in english but we said yeah i
think so so
as we you know get better at the
language we start to
sort of start using those natural
phrases of the language without thinking
of our own but of course there will be
some vestiges of
might be your own language might be
another language so is inter language
really something useful or is it just a
matter of of we are gradually
progressing from a very limited
knowledge in the language to where we
have more and more of the natural
phrases of that language
uh but at times
and particularly for people who speak
many languages they you know we could in
fact be influenced by some other
language so there is always
interference so yeah to that extent
interlanguage exists but i'm not sure
that it describes anything
that has any particular application to
anything we just have to learn the
language hopefully we're motivated to
learn the language and we just continue
as i'm doing with arabic and we struggle
and we have
you know the victories seem few and far
between but lo and behold
even though we felt all the time that we
weren't making much progress after six
months a year or so we find that we're
able to handle the language even with
mistakes whether these mistakes are
influenced by our own language or
another language or just the fact that
we can't remember how to say things
properly anyway bit of a ramble
uh i hope that answers the gentleman who
asked about andrew slavic and uh bye for
now
[Music]
you